♪♪
-Larva is singular.
Larvae is plural.
The actor in "Goliath Awaits"
is named Robert Forster,
not Robert Forrester.
Shame on me.
He's a wonderful actor.
"Jackie Brown?"
[ Silence ]
[ Light laughter ]
We said we were going
to keep showing clips
from "Goliath Awaits,"
but we did not have
permission last week
and now we're in a bit
of a legal tangle
with Larry White Productions.
This is fascinating -- I saw
this on the Wikipedia page.
The original "Goliath Awaits"
is 200 minutes,
but if you get it on VHS,
it's only 110 minutes.
And I think it says a lot
about the script
that you can cut out
90 minutes
and maintain the integrity
of the story.
[ Laughter ]
I guess it was originally
110 minutes,
but in order to make
it a two-night...
miniseries event, they needed
to get it up to 200 minutes.
And if you're wondering how
they took 110 minutes script
and got to 200 minutes,
they had Reese do a pass.
[ Laughter ]
Now, Seth Reese,
that's our writer.
and again, that was a burn.
Not particularly a fair one.
But in return for the burn,
I'm going to remind you
he's got a new film
coming out called "The Menu."
This is a --
This is not me joking around.
This is a "Vanity Fair"
headline --
"'The Menu' is not what
you expect -- it's better."
So keep an eye out
for "The Menu,"
and you'll continue, obviously,
to see us plugging it here
because we are going to
continue to burn Reese
and feel bad about it.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, I said clouds were made
from "da air,"
when in fact, they're made from
water droplets or ice crystals.
In my defense, I did say
they were made from "da air"
from the perspective
of Mike Lindell,
as evidenced by the fact that
instead of saying "the air,"
"da air."
And I feel like
when I'm in character
that you cannot correct that,
when I'm in the middle
of one of my impressions,
because that's not me anymore.
That's someone
speaking through me.
That's why the impressions
are so good.
I'm channeling them,
and it feels seamless
when you watch A Closer Look
and you see me doing
someone like Mike Lindell,
but we have to make edits
because obviously,
for people in the studio,
they know that before I do
a Mike Lindell,
it's like... [ Gurgles ]
[ Laughter ]
It's pretty long.
It's like an incantation
and a pretty --
it's not fun to be here live.
[ Laughter ]
We mentioned a cheese ball tub
full of Xanax
and we showed a graphic,
and according to many of you,
the pills in the tub were
the wrong shape to be Xanax.
So for everyone
who pointed that out,
I know this goes without saying,
but you gotta to relax.
[ Laughter ]
Costco doesn't sell giant tubs
of cheese ball.
This is actually --
I'm reading this verbatim.
This is something
that was said in --
"Costco doesn't sell
giant tubs of cheese balls.
Do you even have
a Costco membership?"
I do not.
[ Laughter ]
Not only do I not buy
my cheese balls in bulk,
I buy them one at a time.
[ Laughter ]
Go to my artisanal
cheese ball guy.
"Just one, Pierre -- Brie."
[ Laughter ]
But nobody in Manhattan
shops at Costco.
That's the reality of it.
Nobody has space.
Should we buy bulk cheese balls
or have a sink?
[ Laughter ]
[ Clears throat ]
I said "mashinations."
I was told it was
"machinations."
I do know it's "machinations,"
but I avoid saying
"mack" just in general
because it reminds me
of you know who --
this -- this monster.
This -- Who's scarier?
Really, just real quick.
Who do you think is scarier,
"Black Phone" dude
or Mack the Knife?
[ Laughter ]
♪ If you like burgers,
get in my van, kids ♪
[ Laughter ]
I called the new break off
golf league
that's competing with the PGA,
I called it L-I-V.
I guess it's "LIV."
And so I apologize.
The last thing
I ever want to do
is offend a Saudi-backed
golf league.
My apologies to the Saudi
royal family,
especially M-B-S.
Sorry, MBS.
[ Laughter ]
I talked about
"The Little Mermaid."
I said Aree-elle
instead of Ari-el.
I can explain.
I have a sister in law
whose name is Ariel,
and when I first met her,
I accidentally said Ariel
and she slapped me in the face.
So now I'm gun shy
to say Ariel.
I just -- When I know --
Even when I know it's Ariel,
I say Ariel.
And it's funny, there,
about accidentally calling
my sister in law Ariel
because she's more of an Ursula.
[ Laughter ]
♪ This is why it's great
that no one in my family ♪
♪ Watches Corrections ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ They don't even know
it's a thing ♪
[ Laughter ]
"Why do you get home
late on Thursdays now?"
♪ I'll never tell ♪
[ Laughter ]
Hey, so, in Jokes I Can't Tell,
we said that some
"Lord of the Rings" fans
are expressing anger
about Black hobbits.
And a lot of
"Lord of the Rings" fans said,
"Hey, that's very unfair
to say that.
You should have said
some bigots.
Like, it's very unfair to,
you know, lump all of us
'Lord of the Rings'
fans together."
And that's very --
that's a very fair criticism.
And I do want to apologize.
You know, I think the only thing
that it's safe to say about
all "Lord of the Rings" fans,
because, of course,
they contain multitudes --
the only thing
that's true of all of you
is you're incapable
of being bored.
[ Laughter ]
We always end
Jokes Seth Can't Tell
by saying Black women
and lesbians are liars,
and when one of you said,
"What about Black lesbians?"
It's weird.
They're very honest.
It's like a double negative
situation.
Wanda Sykes tells you something?
Take it to the grave.
Hey, it's - it's Twinings,
not Twinnings.
I just genuinely didn't know
that, but I messed that up.
Also, the Queen drank
Gordon's gin, not Beefeater.
Vegan.
[ Laughter ]
Where...
[ Laughs, clears throat ]
Oh, this is cool.
You guys, Detroit style pizza
is back at Pizza Hut,
third year in a row
that they brought it back.
Their rectangular-shaped pie
with a thick,
crispy crust edge comes loaded
with your choice of toppings
and premium
vine-ripened tomato sauce.
And, you know, I said it before.
I'll say it again.
No one out-pizzas the Hut.
And that's just --
this is something I believe.
[ Laughter ]
Okay?
This is me sharing some --
It's not even a correction.
I mean, the correction
was Detroit style pizza was gone
and now it's back again.
Because again, if that was -- if
that was a paid consideration
furnished by Pizza Hut,
we legally would have to put it
on a chyron
that we'd keep up for, like,
two and a half seconds.
I'm not just allowed to say it.
I will say,
it would be pretty cool
if a brand decided
to pay some money
to get their name
in Corrections.
[ Laughter ]
If I was a jackal, trying to
decide between two pizza places,
that might tip the scales.
[ Laughter ]
Pretty cool.
Maybe a wake-up call
for other brands out there.
[ Laughter ]
Get a bidding war going.
Hey, sometimes I got
to give jackals credit
where credit is due -- I talked
about Jacques Cousteau's
short-lived 1960s
[French accent] Canal+
[normally] prank show "Jaque'd."
The only downside is
more than one of you
had a better one,
and to be honest,
I'm more impressed
when it's just one person.
But this would have been better.
Congratulations, jackals.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, there was such a --
it was all sort
of sea life-style pranks.
And there was a really
good episode where
their Steve-O,
Etienne Oh.
[ Laughter ]
It was called the sperm whale,
and it wasn't the mammal.
[ Laughter ]
We mentioned the Cake song --
the band Cake's song
"Going the Distance,"
you know, which obviously,
I don't have to tell you
is on the album
"Fashion Nugget."
But then when we put up the key,
the key was the album
"Prolonging the Magic."
And I was obviously as surprised
as anybody else
in A Closer Look,
and you could feel the gasp
from the audience
because everybody,
I think, both was on board
with the Cake reference
and very surprised
that we put up the wrong album.
And and so I went --
I went down to Graphics
and wanted to unload on them,
but they weren't the problem.
The problem was
one of our producers,
Emily Erotas, is a huge --
just a huge Cake fan.
[ Laughter ]
She's a Cake head.
A great producer --
fast, thorough, sharp as a tack,
but she's always felt
very strongly
that "Prolonging the Magic"
is THE Cake album.
And so I guess she overruled
the graphics department,
and I just went, "Ugh."
I mean, I marched into
her office and I'm like,
"Do you really think
'Prolonging the Magic'
is better than
'Fashion Nugget?'"
And she was like, "Yes, I do."
And I'm like,
"Even after Damiani
and Brown left?"
And she's like,
"Because they left."
And then you're just like,
enough.
[ Laughter ]
When you're arguing Cake
with Emily,
it's just sometimes
just better to walk away.
[ Laughter ]
You can legally drive
a golf court --
a golf cart
on the highway in Florida
as long as can reach a minimum
speed of 40 miles per hour.
Someone told me this and said
if I didn't believe him,
I could look it up
in the Florida statutes
for motor vehicles.
So I looked up
the Florida statutes for,
you know, motor vehicles
and I decided I would just,
like, open Apple+F
old "golf carts" to go to,
you know, the one mention.
Guess how many times
"golf carts"
is mentioned in the Florida
statutes for motor vehicles?
57 times.
Tell me you're a legal document
from Florida without telling me
you're a legal document
from Florida.
Oh. So we were talking about --
I accidentally said The Fonzie,
and then I explained it
by saying I was talking about
the Russian "Happy Days,"
which of course, we mentioned
is called...
That was who
The Fonzie was from.
But a lot of you said
there is no word for "the"
in the Russian language.
So the only way to distinguish
one Fonzie
from the other Fonzies
in Russian
would be to call him
Only Fonzie.
And I think that's better.
If instead of the Fonz,
it was Only Fonz.
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
Heyyy, Only Fonz.
And then, you know --
someone was -- you know --
And again, I --
Credit where credit is due,
I thought maybe I should write
the full lyrics to
"These Days, While Not Happy,
are Still Days,"
but one -- a jackal did,
and I'd just like to read them
because I do actually think
it's a beautiful piece of work.
And again, so this would be,
obviously --
this would be a show
that came out, you know,
based on --
the world we're setting up here
would be on television in Russia
from like '74 to '84,
but it would be about Russia
in the '50s,
just like our "Happy Days."
You follow, Shoemaker?
Do you follow?
[ Laughter ]
I wish you could see his face.
He's like...
All right. Here we go.
[Russian accent] ♪ Sunday,
Monday, these are days ♪
♪ Tuesday, Wednesday,
also days ♪
♪ Thursday, Friday, again,
are days ♪
♪ No weekends, work begins ♪
♪ Stalin is great for you ♪
♪ These days are devoid of joy ♪
♪ That's every day ♪
[ Laughter ]
[Normally] Again, this is based
on the previous Russia.
The not fun one.
[ Laughter ]
Well...
"The Menu," in theaters...
What?
Not anymore?
[ Laughter ]
All right, you guys.
I'm very happy
to be with you again.
Hey, why don't you see me
next week?